i'm still waiting to hear that song
about ryan tannehill he is in nashville
will he stay in nashville he's due to
become a free agent so is running back
derrick henry and derek henry recently
had this to say chris in reaction to
all of the chatter about tom brady
possibly joining the titans brady can
still play obviously age doesn't matter
for him he's still playing at a high
level my question would be why ain't
ryan good enough speaking for everyone
on the offense we fed off of him ryan
tannehill's our quarterback we went to
the fc championship why would we not
want ryan back your reaction well this
is what i wanted to grieve about you
know i was going to kind of lump tannen
hill and and dak prescott into this
conversation because i'm sick of it you
know i i just hear it too much right now
like oh tom brady tennessee titans yeah
oh yeah what everybody's out there
you're crazy tom brady is not as good as
ryan tannenhill right now i'm just sorry
you know i know tom brady is arguably
the greatest quarterback ever certainly
the most accomplished the man but that
doesn't mean he's the best in 2020 and
ryan tannehill
was great last year i don't think that
that the tennessee titans would have had
the same results if tom brady was in the
game for the tennessee titans you know
like listen the the the titans weren't
like a team where we're going whoa they
got weapons galore they didn't have
great weapons too we didn't really know
about aj brown until ryan tannehill got
in there how many times did we make
tapes and talk about this on the show
mike where guys weren't open and tanned
hill was just hitting the bullseye 40
yards down the field 30 yards down the
field you know and then of course his
athleticism to go with it so yeah why he
was you know arguably other than derek
henry he would be the second guy you
would say would be the mvp of the team
so i i just don't understand that either
i think we got to get away from you know
what i always say there's just this oh
franchise guy and this is the guy where
it's warm and cozy and we feel good
about that and it's the only guy we can
win no you can win with more than you
know three guys in the nfl
let me say this though and as it relates
to tom brady at the cowboys tom brady at
the titans i think brady locks makes a
lot more sense in dallas because of what
the cowboys are trying to do which is
win another super bowl asafp
in tennessee i think it makes more sense
to stick with ryan tanner well here's
the caveat though what we saw last year
from ryan tannehill was a guy who was in
full blown nothing to lose mode he had
played out his rookie deal he had a
second contract with the dolphins
and he gets this chance after the
dolphins are paying
a large chunk of his salary to
facilitate the trade that happened last
year to tennessee he's loose he's free
he's just out there playing the game not
knowing whether or not there's going to
be a tomorrow whether because of injury
or ineffectiveness and it worked the
planets lined up and it was special my
concern is once he's re-established once
he gets a big contract what happens and
he's got an injury history that's right
and those clips that we're playing he is
throwing his body around he's not going
to be doing that if he is a
franchise-level quarterback who's got a
25 to 30 million dollar per year
contract that goes along with it so
that's my concern we've seen that before
with running backs and defensive tackles
and i kind of have that concern with
ryan tannehill after you give him big
money
what happens that would be my concern
yeah i mean that's a fair question but i
think as you and i both know because we
dug into this a little lat you know last
year at the end of the 2018 season
tannehill's time in miami when you
really dig into it is a lot more
impressive than i think we give it
credit for when we just look at it at
surface level now the injury history is
real you're right so that's that's scary
you know but you know i think this year
has got to give that the tennessee
titans you know confidence that okay
you know he's overcome the acl knee
injury and he should be good from here
to from here on out so i get it and i
understand tom brady's a legend and
everybody would love for him to come to
town i'm just saying to the dallas fan
base the tennessee fan base he is not as
good as those two quarterbacks he's not
you know and i don't i don't agree with
your sentiment about you know i
understand your logic about you saying
brady to the cowboys chris chris they
were eight and eight with dak prescott
last year okay they had a whole lot of
issues it wasn't just dak prescott i
mean there was more so what you know
again and you know the injury concern
thing where i'll just say this is you
know brady's was beat up too at the end
of the year last year i mean he came out
and let people know how banged up he was
when it was all said and done so you got
to worry about the injury with him too
at some point even though he's been the
iron man to a degree
well but the thing is he's going to be
43 in august i'd go with tannehill over
brady and i'm i'm i'm fascinated by the
possibility of bill crazy getting out of
crazyville jerk man fascinating you're
crazy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports